tenir le corail mémoire de la planète en
polynésie des scientifiques veulent en
savoir plus sur l'histoire d'el niño ce
phénomène qui m'était climatique
synonyme de catastrophe ils sont allés
prélever des carottes de corail dans les
îles isolées des tuamotu en 83 puis 190
fake des cyclones ravage la polynésie
leurs forces sur temps à population à
l'origine du phénomène la hausse des
températures de l'eau de mer depuis
trente ans les scientifiques tentent de
mieux connaître lignot en mesurant la
température de l'océan pacifique
les plus anciennes données datent des
années 70 avant c'est l'inconnu pour en
savoir plus les scientifiques de l'ird
et se sont rendus à tikehau janvier loi
et nuku hiva
il y entre et lever une vingtaine de 6
linge de corps ou les témoins
irréprochable de l'évolution climatique
sur la planète
il ya des éléments chimiques qui sont
contenus dans ce squelette aurélien et
qui sont incorporés en fonction des
températures de l'eau et donc plus on va
pas en trouver deux éléments chimiques -
la température va être élevé donc en
connaissant ces éléments et en
connaissant leur relation avec la
température de l'eau on peut
reconstituer des températures depuis
plusieurs siècles puisque ces carottes
peuvent faire trois quatre cinq mètres
ce qui représente jusqu'à quatre à cinq
siècles les températures câble à 1 de
l'ue devrait créer à partir de 7 ans tes
ratures les scientifiques pourront tirer
des conclusions sur le phénomène
climatique el niño et by cécile il ya
100 200 ou 400 ans en arrière qu'elle
laissait leur fréquence les
scientifiques ont noté cinq événements
les trente dernières années
ce qu'ils font la preuve que ce
phénomène est cyclique et existe depuis
plusieurs centaines d'années
l'effet de serre ne pourra plus alors
être mis en cause et la force et la
fréquence des phénomènes pourraient être
prévues à l'avant